Il y a dix millions d'années,
quelques créatures se mettent debout.
Ces étranges mammifères sont en danger.
Ils ont peu de chance de survivre.
Alors ils se défendent et s'adaptent.
Ils inventent, ils marchent,
ils parcourent la terre et les océans.
Ils explorent et conquièrent le monde.
Nous sommes leurs enfants.
Que notre peau soit
blanche, noire ou cuivrée,
nous descendons tous
d'une seule et même famille.
Dix millions d'années,
c'est 500 000 générations.
Inlassablement,
nos aïeux ont transmis
leur savoir à leurs enfants
pour qu'il arrive jusqu'à nous.
Aujourd'hui, ce savoir
nous permet de remonter jusqu'à eux,
de fouiller notre passé
et d'y trouver leurs traces.
Voici l'extraordinaire
odyssée de notre grande famille.
L'odyssée de l'espèce.
Comment débute cette histoire ?
Qui est le premier d'entre nous ?
Comment est-il arrivé ?
Un singe étrange va naître,
un peu différent des autres.
Ses parents vivent dans les arbres.
Ils dorment,
cramponnés aux branches,
dans la terreur
des prédateurs qui rôdent sur le sol.
Lui, non.
Il ne vivra pas comme eux.
Il va quitter les arbres
et se dresser sur ses pattes arrière.
Son audace le porte.
Il explore le monde d'en bas.
Il faut qu'il découvre
une autre façon de vivre.
Le premier pré-humain arrive
et il va changer la face du monde.
Le voyage commence,
il faut remonter le temps.
Imaginez.
Nous sommes à -10 millions d'années.
Les dinosaures ont disparu
depuis 50 millions d'années.
D'autres formes de vie de plus en plus
élaborées continuent de se développer.
Les mammifères se multiplient.
La dérive des continents a donné
à la terre le visage qu'on lui connaît.
Dans les grandes forêts africaines,
plusieurs espèces
de primates s'épanouissent.
Ces populations de singes vont se faire
piéger par une catastrophe naturelle.
Sous la pression de forces telluriques,
le continent africain se déchire.
Les singes sont pris dans la tourmente.
L'immense faille du grand rift se forme.
À l'ouest de cette faille,
une barrière montagneuse
qui arrête les pluies.
À l'est,
un haut plateau, puis la mer.
La faille devient une barrière
sur des centaines de kilomètres.
De part et d'autre, la vie va suivre
des chemins radicalement différents.
Les singes survivants
sont divisés en deux groupes :
ceux de la forêt et ceux de la savane.
Ce sont ceux
de la savane qui vont trinquer.
Sous l'effet du changement climatique,
la grande forêt a disparu.
Les singes de la savane
sont menacés d'extinction.
Disséminés, les clans se partagent
les quelques arbres qui subsistent.
Ils s'accrochent aux dernières
ressources de la vie arboricole.
Mais la vie dans les arbres est un piège.
On y meurt de faim.
Il faut descendre ou mourir.
Le premier d'entre nous
va naître dans ces conditions difficiles.
Ses parents n'ont rien pour le nourrir.
La savane s'ouvre à perte de vue,
pleine de danger.
Il a peur.
Il pourrait renoncer et attendre,
mais un extraordinaire
instinct de survie l'habite.
Aucun d'entre eux n'a jamais fait ça.
Il va prendre un risque énorme.
Son malheur va le pousser
à faire une découverte prodigieuse.
Il mesure 1,30 mètre.
À quatre pattes dans la savane,
il ne sait plus où il va.
Alors, il se dresse
sur ses deux pattes arrière.
Et là, il voit.
Il voit.
Il observe.
Dès qu'il veut se déplacer,
ça recommence.
Être à quatre pattes l'empêche de voir.
Alors, il a une deuxième intuition.
Il va avancer, mais debout
et le plus longtemps possible.
Ça y est.
Il est bipède.
Ce n'est pas une attitude naturelle
pour un singe, mais ça fonctionne.
Maintenant, il n'est plus un singe.
Il s'appelle Orrorin.
Les premiers pas le rassurent.
Peut-être même éprouve-t-il
le plaisir de la nouveauté.
De là-haut,
Orrorin se sent plus grand,
plus fort,
et il peut voir les siens de loin.
La longue marche commence.
Orrorin fait confiance à son flair.
Il doit trouver à manger
et un nouveau refuge.
Et bientôt, la fatigue se fait ressentir,
ses jambes se raidissent.
Cette démarche tire
sur les muscles du dos.
Alors, il doit s'arrêter souvent
et attendre que ses forces reviennent.
Inévitablement,
un dents-de-sabre est à l'affût,
prêt à dévorer
tous les faibles et les isolés.
Il sera notre pire cauchemar
tout au long de la route.
Dans ces temps farouches,
la vie ne tient qu'à un fil.
Personne ne sait vraiment
se défendre contre les prédateurs.
Chacun sauve sa peau comme il peut.
Sur son chemin,
la famille d'Orrorin
perdra beaucoup des siens
pendant le jour
et aussi pendant la nuit.
Mais qu'importe.
S'il en reste suffisamment
pour se reproduire, l'espèce continuera.
À 2000 kilomètres de là,
un autre grand singe s'est mis debout.
Il s'appelle Toumaï.
La nouvelle s'est-elle
répandue jusque-là ?
Pure coïncidence ?
On ne sait pas.
Ceux qui ont continué sur deux pieds
sont devenus des hommes, ou presque.
Il leur a fallu des milliers d'années
pour s'adapter à cette nouvelle position,
à cette nouvelle vie.
Des milliers d'années pour apprendre
que leurs pattes avant étaient devenues
des bras et que leurs mains
libérées pouvaient leur servir
à faire mille choses utiles.
Il y eut des jours
de grand découragement,
et d'autres plus paisibles.
Orrorin et Toumaï vivaient
en paix avec beaucoup d'espèces
comme le calicotère.
Ni proie, ni prédateur,
juste un voisin agréable.
Pendant des centaines
de milliers d'années,
Orrorin et Toumaï
vont explorer leur territoire.
Ils auront des enfants
et des petits enfants
à qui ils légueront
leur formidable découverte,
puis ils laisseront
leur place à de nouvelles lignées.
On ne sait pas
comment ils ont disparu.
Les conditions de vie vont encore changer.
Pendant des siècles,
la sécheresse agresse
la végétation et la faune.
Nos ancêtres sont soumis
à une pression croissante.
S'adapter, changer ou disparaître.
Les survivants errent maintenant
sur un grand territoire de savane arborée
qui va de l'Éthiopie au Tchad
et à l'Afrique du Sud.
Leur vie devient un combat.
L'eau est une denrée rare.
Il fait chaud.
Le soleil est rude pour ceux
qui n'ont pas trouvé une place à l'ombre.
De nombreuses espèces disparaissent,
comme le calicotère.
Seuls quelques hominiens audacieux
et mieux adaptés vont parvenir à survivre.
Les australopithèques.
Plusieurs espèces différentes les unes
des autres se partagent la plaine.
Un seul d'entre eux
peut avoir enfanté l'espèce humaine.
Nos regards se tournent vers une femme,
une femme qui pourrait
bien être notre grand-mère.
Cette femme, c'est Lucy.
Et voilà ce que l'on imagine
de son histoire.
Lucy vit dans la vallée de l'Awash.
Tous ses proches ont disparu.
Depuis quelque temps,
elle mène une vie solitaire
dans la crainte et l'angoisse.
Elle a 20 ans
et a déjà eu quatre enfants.
Elle pourrait se laisser mourir,
mais elle attend le cinquième.
Elle sent une présence.
Un espoir fait battre son cœur.
Un petit groupe,
bipède comme elle.
Ils ne sont pas de la même espèce.
C'est dangereux,
mais Lucy veut quand même les approcher.
L'envie de faire partie
d'un groupe à nouveau,
de trouver une protection
pour l'enfant qu'elle porte.
S'ils ne l'acceptent pas,
quel danger court-elle ?
Ils peuvent la tuer et la manger,
mais l'envie est plus forte.
Lucy est une Afarensis.
Les autres hominiens viennent d'ailleurs.
Ce sont des Anamensis.
Ils n'ont pas l'air d'avoir peur.
Jamais Lucy ne s'allongera comme ça
au milieu de la savane pour se reposer.
Elle ne peut communiquer avec eux.
Ils n'ont en commun
ni langage, ni odeur, ni mode de vie,
ni même de reproduction
possible avec elle.
Comment les approcher ?
Il faut attendre,
attendre qu'ils la trouvent,
attendre qu'ils la voient.
C'est un mâle très puissant.
Pour se faire accepter,
Lucy n'a qu'une solution :
la soumission.
Et peut-être aussi la séduction.
Les Anamensis ne vivent pas comme Lucy.
Ils sont prêts à se battre
avec ceux qui vivent sur le sol
pour leur voler leur nourriture.
Ils sont charognards.
Quand on est charognard,
il faut être opportuniste.
Lucy a été acceptée parmi eux,
mais elle est surprise
par tout ce qu'ils font.
Elle n'aurait jamais attaqué ces hyènes.
Elle n'aurait jamais eu
l'idée de manger cette chose.
Tout ça, les anciens ne le faisaient pas.
D'habitude, Lucy se nourrit
de fruits, d'insectes, de plantes.
Il lui est arrivé de manger
des petits animaux morts.
Mais ça.
Si elle veut rester dans ce clan,
il faut pourtant qu'elle s'habitue,
qu'elle fasse comme eux.
Tous les jours,
les Anamensis marchent longtemps.
Lucy se fatigue, mais pas eux.
Elle a faim tout le temps.
Son enfant grandit dans son corps
et prend beaucoup de ses forces.
Le chef du groupe la suit partout.
Même s'il ne l'aide pas
à trouver sa nourriture,
il la surveille et la protège.
Mais Lucie n'est pas prête à copuler.
Un autre mâle, plus jeune,
a décidé d'affronter le chef pour Lucie.
Le chef n'est plus le chef.
Il doit renoncer
pour un temps face à son concurrent.
Lucy change de protecteur,
mais sa racine
est toujours accrochée au sol,
et elle veut cette racine.
Quand même, il s'est battu pour elle.
Il lui a fallu marcher
des jours et des jours
dans ces cailloux
qui lui coupent les pieds,
chercher sous les pierres
des insectes à manger,
sur les feuilles de la rosée à boire,
toujours trouver
de nouvelles charognes fraîches.
Et pour ça,
il faut faire beaucoup de chemin.
Mais la vie de Lucy
est redevenue plus douce
car elle a quelqu'un auprès d'elle,
quelqu'un qu'elle peut toucher,
quelqu'un qui la rassure
et qui parfois même
lui apporte de la nourriture.
Aujourd'hui, un obstacle
s'est présenté sur leur chemin.
Un obstacle que Lucy n'a jamais franchi.
Les australopithèques ne savent pas nager,
mais les Anamensis ont appris à traverser
les rivières
en suivant les autres animaux.
L'ancien chef cherche
l'endroit le moins profond pour traverser.
Il a trouvé des traces d'animaux
de ce côté et de l'autre aussi.
Ce sera le chemin.
Il y a aussi les grandes bouches.
De nombreuses fois,
les Anamensis ont perdu un des leurs
à cause de ces grandes gueules
pleines de dents qui vivent sous l'eau.
Lucie sent ses forces l'abandonner
et elle espère qu'ils renonceront.
Son ventre pèse.
Elle ne veut pas aller plus loin.
Eux, ils passent.
Elle va rester seule ici.
Elle ne veut plus être seule.
Son enfant ne survivra pas.
Mais Lucy a les jambes
trop courtes et trop lourdes.
Elle ne peut pas résister au courant.
Lucy s'est noyée.
Le jeune mâle a déjà vu
beaucoup des siens disparaître.
L'image de Lucy
est restée dans sa tête, un peu,
puis il l'a oubliée.
Il faut marcher,
suivre les autres sans se retourner.
Lucy n'est peut-être pas
la grand-mère de l'humanité.
Parce qu'il marche mieux,
parce que son audace l'a amené plus loin,
Anamensis pourrait
bien être notre ancêtre.
Le corps de Lucy s'est déposé
dans le lit d'un fleuve d'Éthiopie
et y est resté
jusqu'à ce qu'on la retrouve.
Nous sommes à -3 millions d'années.
Un autre grand tournant
de notre préhistoire va avoir lieu.
Le premier véritable homme
est sur le point de naître.
Un changement de climat sera
encore à l'origine de cette naissance.
La grande glaciation.
Au pôle,
une calotte glaciaire se forme
en solidifiant
des milliards de litres d'eau.
Le niveau de tous
les océans baisse d'autant,
il fait plus froid et il pleut moins.
En Afrique,
la sécheresse s'accroît brutalement.
Les nuages venant
de l'Atlantique n'arrivent plus.
Peu d'australopithèques vont résister.
Un nouvel hominien arrive,
un des plus grands
inventeurs de notre famille.
Homo habilis, l'homme habile.
Son invention va changer notre destin.
Si Homo habilis est plus grand
que ses prédécesseurs,
la vraie différence
se cache dans son crâne.
Dans son cerveau plus volumineux,
des idées plus élaborées
sont prêtes à germer.
Son audace le pousse à aller plus loin.
Un crocodile. Vivant ou mort ?
Il faut essayer.
C'est dangereux, mais il y a une chance.
Le monstre ne bouge plus.
Malgré le danger, malgré la peur,
Habilis ose
ce que ses ancêtres n'ont jamais fait,
et il lui arrive de réussir.
Il ne sait pas encore
que cette capture va lui apporter
beaucoup plus que de la nourriture.
Chaque jour, Habilis s'interroge
sur les mystères de la nature.
Son esprit s'éveille,
il cherche à comprendre.
La pierre coupe la pierre.
La pierre coupée coupe la main.
Si elle coupe la main,
la pierre coupée peut couper autre chose.
Le clan est revenu démarrer
avec 100 kilos de viande,
de quoi se nourrir
pendant plusieurs semaines,
mais cette viande
est protégée par une peau trop dure.
Ni les mains, ni les dents
ne peuvent la déchirer.
Il faut trouver un moyen.
La pierre coupée coupe la main.
Notre jeune inventeur aimerait essayer.
Mais le clan est en rage.
Toute cette nourriture-là
est pourtant inaccessible.
Pendant qu'ils se chamaillent,
le jeune Habilis suit
cette idée qui taraude son esprit.
Son idée est l'objectif.
Si la pierre coupée tranche la main,
elle peut ouvrir l'animal.
Sans le savoir, le jeune Habilis
vient de faire une invention phénoménale :
l'outil.
La surprise est vite passée.
La viande est là,
et peu importe comment,
les favorites des plus forts
sont servies les premières.
Habilis, l'ancien,
veut comprendre ce qui s'est passé.
Il doit prendre le pouvoir
de cette pierre pour lui.
Elle doit ouvrir
le crocodile par sa main.
Il a le pouvoir.
Habilis, l'ancien,
sera toujours l'ancien
et cette pierre est pour lui.
Le grand événement,
ce n'est pas l'utilisation d'un outil.
Le vrai prodige,
c'est la création de l'outil lui-même.
Dès l'instant où il invente
l'outil à découper la viande,
Habilis se nourrit mieux.
Grâce aux protéines,
son cerveau se développe
et notre génie invente d'autres outils,
et grâce à eux,
d'autres stratégies pour survivre.
Quand Habilis a un objectif,
il cherche une idée
qui va lui permettre de l'atteindre.
Mais pour savoir si l'idée fonctionne,
il faut l'essayer.
Alors on l'essaie,
à moindre frais.
Si ça fonctionne,
généralement on le sait très vite.
Alors on évalue.
On mesure l'efficacité.
Cette nouvelle façon
d'utiliser nos méninges marque le début
de l'action de l'homme sur le monde.
L'avantage de ce mode de pensée,
c'est qu'il est reproductible.
Il rend toute découverte ingénieuse
à la portée de tout le monde.
Le savoir se transmet
très rapidement par imitation.
L'autre avantage,
c'est qu'en passant de main en main,
la technique se perfectionne
avec le temps.
C'est une réaction en chaîne.
Dès lors, rien ne pourra
plus arrêter notre évolution.
L'inconvénient, c'est que la création
va aussi changer notre comportement
et que certains vont commencer à croire
qu'ils sont plus malins que les autres.
Habilis est le tout premier à pouvoir
être véritablement appelé un homme.
Explorateur, inventeur,
manipulateur d'idées, homme de pouvoir.
Grâce à ces nouvelles armes
qui l'accompagnent en milieu hostile,
il est maintenant plus sûr de lui.
Avec le partage du savoir,
les liens entre les membres
du groupe se resserrent.
Il y a plus de solidarité
et le clan est mieux armé
contre les dangers extérieurs.
L'ancien a décidé qu'il ne fallait plus
avoir peur des grands animaux.
Son pouvoir et sa lance
lui donnent du courage.
Il faut qu'il puisse
se défendre sur le sol.
Comment se protéger lorsqu'on dort
et qu'on n'est plus dans les arbres ?
Beaucoup se sont fait prendre
alors qu'ils avaient les yeux fermés.
Une nouvelle idée a germé.
L'ancien veut que l'on ramasse
tout ce qui est sur le sol.
Cette invention demande
la participation de tout le clan.
Des pierres !
Il lui faut des pierres.
Tiens, celle-ci est coupante,
très coupante.
Il lui faut des pierres,
mais aussi des branches.
Habilis, l'ancien, tente
d'organiser la répartition du travail.
Partage des tâches,
partage de la nourriture ou des outils,
l'organisation du clan se perfectionne.
La société des hommes,
ses conflits et ses rivalités,
est en train de naître.
Drôle d'invention.
Des pierres qui tiennent des branches.
Ont-ils voulu retrouver sur le sol
l'atmosphère sécurisante de l'arbre ?
Se sont-ils inspirés des nids d'oiseaux ?
Habilis est le premier
à construire des abris.
On refait des petits arbres par terre
comme si on y était.
Toutes les pierres
ne deviennent pas coupantes.
Certaines s'effritent
et ne donnent rien d'utile.
Il y en a qui sont
très précieuses, très pratiques.
Il faut apprendre à les reconnaître.
Il faut se souvenir de leur couleur.
Il faut se souvenir de leur odeur.
Il faut garder
la connaissance dans la tête
et l'apprendre aux autres,
à tous les autres.
Habilis ne sait pas qu'il est
à l'origine d'un phénomène éternel :
l'enseignement de la connaissance.
La nuit tombe
sur ces hommes remarquables.
Combien étaient-ils ?
100 000 ?
Au plus, 200 000.
Homo habilis vivra
pendant des millénaires
et verra même
ses cousins australopithèques disparaître.
Il laisse derrière lui
un esprit de conquête,
une idée de la vie
où rien n'est impossible.
Son esprit est présent
chez l'homme d'aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes à -2 million d'années.
La suite de notre histoire
se jouera le long d'un incroyable voyage.
Le berceau de l'humanité
est maintenant le théâtre
d'une âpre compétition entre Habilis
et toutes les autres espèces d'hominidés.
Pression démographique,
curiosité et bougeotte vont pousser
quelques familles à se déplacer.
Laissant derrière lui l'Afrique tropicale,
un nouvel homme
est en train de voir le jour.
Son corps s'adapte au long voyage.
Ses outils se perfectionnent.
Homo ergaster est en route.
Parmi nos ancêtres,
Ergaster est le conquérant.
Il va découvrir le monde,
une terre vierge prête à être explorée.
Génération après génération,
au gré des glaciations
qui font baisser le niveau des mers
ou des réchauffements
qui les font remonter,
les hommes peuplent la terre,
pas encore toute la terre,
mais déjà toutes les terres
qu'ils peuvent atteindre.
Ils parcourent des distances
qu'ils ne savent pas mesurer,
gagnent des territoires
dont ils n'avaient pas idée.
Qu'est-ce qui les pousse
ainsi dans un monde inconnu ?
Suivent-ils des troupeaux d'animaux ?
Ou est-ce cette envie
d'aller toujours plus loin,
de franchir les limites ?
Cet esprit de conquête
qu'Habilis lui a laissé.
Ergaster est plus grand.
Il se tient plus droit,
consomme moins d'énergie
et peut couvrir de plus grandes distances
sans boire ni manger.
Son cerveau continue de grandir.
Il va non seulement
faire des inventions prodigieuses,
mais aussi découvrir
de nouveaux rapports sociaux,
de nouveaux sentiments.
Les épreuves du voyage
vont faire de lui un autre homme
dans sa perception
de lui-même, des autres et du monde.
Cet homme a maintenant conscience
qu'il fait partie d'un groupe,
que ce groupe le protège
et que la survie
du groupe dépend de chacun.
Il sait qu'il a besoin des autres
et il est prêt à donner la main,
à aider son prochain.
C'est un nouveau comportement
et il va resserrer les liens affectifs
qui nous unissent depuis si longtemps.
La perte d'un proche est un déchirement.
Même s'il est habitué
aux dangers du voyage,
Ergaster ne veut plus
accepter cette fatalité.
Le clan s'est arrêté
pour reprendre quelques forces,
mais un climat
de détresse plane sur le groupe.
Ergaster souffre.
Le souvenir de cette femme
reste présent dans sa mémoire.
Il revit les moments
qu'il a passés à ses côtés.
Elle lui manque.
Ergaster ne comprend pas.
Elle est là, dans sa tête,
mais plus à côté de lui.
Pourquoi ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait couler
de l'eau sur son visage ?
Elle ne reviendra pas.
Ergaster commence à prendre
conscience du temps qui passe.
Peut-être pense-t-il à la mort,
à sa propre mort.
Les autres membres du clan
ressentent aussi la douleur de l'homme.
Ils souffrent avec lui,
car ils ont conscience
de la fragilité de leur vie.
Le grand voyage continue.
Il dure des millénaires.
Ergaster s'adapte
à de nouvelles conditions et il évolue.
Quand il arrive en Asie,
il a grimpé d'un degré
dans la compréhension du monde.
Il est devenu
celui qu'on appelle Homo erectus,
l'homme dressé.
Plus qu'aucun autre,
il va soumettre la nature.
Fini le temps
où l'on se nourrissait de charogne.
Erectus est maintenant
un vrai prédateur.
Il apprend à utiliser
ses armes pour chasser
et à se procurer la seule nourriture
disponible en toutes saisons :
la viande fraîche.
Pour manger, il tue.
Il devient même un super prédateur.
En utilisant la force du groupe,
il rivalise avec les loups et les lions.
La chasse est une nouvelle activité
qui modifie nos mœurs et notre corps.
On y passe beaucoup de temps
et on mange plus de viande.
Dans un groupe,
les tâches sont réparties.
On commence à se spécialiser.
Certains se chargent
de partager la nourriture
pendant que l'homme
qui a chassé se repose.
Chacun a son rôle.
Le partage crée des obligations.
Les différents morceaux de l'animal
sont attribués, même réservés à certains.
Les adultes sont servis les premiers.
Les enfants doivent attendre,
et si possible demander.
Mais enfreindre les règles
fait aussi partie de l'éducation.
Pour notre corps,
le changement est d'importance.
La viande pleine de protéines
nourrit et accélère le développement
de notre cerveau.
La famille erectus est aussi plus soudée.
On se protège, on se prévient,
on se soumet à l'autorité des parents
et on s'attache
à ceux qui nous font du bien.
C'est le cinquième serpent tué
depuis que le soleil s'est levé
et il va finir comme les autres.
Pendant que certains
vont chasser ou cueillir des fruits,
d'autres doivent servir la communauté.
Erectus a maintenant besoin
de beaucoup d'outils
destinés à des tâches différentes :
le biface à tout faire,
des percuteurs pour casser les os
et les couteaux pour déguster la moelle.
C'est ainsi que le travail arrive
dans la vie des hommes,
avec ses contraintes.
Fini le temps où l'on pensait au présent
et à ne subvenir qu'à ses propres besoins.
Bienvenue dans les temps modernes.
Tailler des pierres
ne s'apprend pas en un jour.
Si demain les étincelles serviront
dans le quotidien de l'homme,
aujourd'hui, on s'en passerait bien.
Avec la sophistication des outils,
la technique se complique
et il faut plus
de temps pour les fabriquer.
Alors on a besoin
de toute la main d'œuvre disponible,
et d'une main d'œuvre qualifiée.
La formation favorise les échanges
entre les hommes et les femmes,
entre les vieux et les jeunes.
Pour Erectus, le jeune,
il faut désormais
acquérir des connaissances.
Erectus, l'ancien,
ne peut plus chasser,
mais il reste
un excellent tailleur de pierre.
Alors, il apprend aux autres.
L'enseignement prend
une grande place dans la vie du groupe
et les premières écoles
fleurissent avec les joies du plein air.
Entre l'homme et la femme,
les mœurs aussi ont beaucoup évolué.
La copulation ne se fait plus comme avant,
ou plutôt moins rapidement qu'avant.
La séduction s'est raffinée.
Pour arriver à ses fins,
notre homme va devoir
surmonter plusieurs difficultés.
Contrairement à lui,
depuis que la femme s'est mise debout,
ses parties génitales
ne sont plus visibles.
Du coup, l'homme ne sait plus
quand la femme est fécondable.
La femme ne veut pas.
Le moment est mal choisi.
Comment savoir
quand c'est le bon moment ?
Le bon moment arrivera.
Mais il faut pour cela
que notre homme renouvelle ses avances.
L'attirance,
la perte de nos poils
a révélé notre peau.
Les formes de la femme
sont visibles en permanence.
Ses formes qui attirent les regards.
Mais le consentement
de la femme doit être obtenu.
Pour la convaincre,
notre homme utilise
sa voix grave et envoûtante.
La nature fait bien les choses.
Dorénavant,
hommes et femmes seront condamnés
à se chercher continuellement
et à se trouver pour assurer
la continuité de notre espèce.
En Asie, au Proche-Orient,
en Europe, en Afrique,
partout où les hommes se sont installés,
ils suivent la même évolution.
Ils inventent,
transmettent leur savoir
et construisent peu à peu
une société nouvelle
fondée sur l'accumulation
des connaissances.
Ils commencent à se différencier
selon les climats et les milieux.
La couleur de leur peau, leurs cheveux,
la forme de leurs yeux
ne sont plus les mêmes partout,
mais ce sont
des différences superficielles.
Le progrès est en route
et tous les hommes en bénéficient.
L'humanité est sur le point
de faire un bond gigantesque.
Cette fois,
l'homme est lui-même à l'origine
de la révolution qui s'annonce.
Il va faire une découverte
qui va changer sa vie.
La chose est arrivée par hasard,
un matin où l'on allait chasser.
Le borgne était parti devant.
Le borgne est un fouineur,
toujours prêt à mettre son nez
là où il ne devrait pas.
C'est d'ailleurs
ce qui lui a coûté son œil.
On ne sait pas quelle mouche l'a piqué.
Il a voulu s'approcher de cet animal.
Tout le monde sait qu'il ne faut pas.
Comme c'était un petit,
il a quand même voulu voir
de plus près s'il pouvait le tuer.
Quand le clan est arrivé,
on s'est dit qu'il avait perdu la tête.
De mémoire d'homme,
cet animal n'avait causé que des ravages.
Il était dangereux et insaisissable.
Ce qui est arrivé ensuite
est à n'y rien comprendre.
Après qu'il l'ait blessé,
l'animal l'a suivi,
ou plutôt une partie
plus petite de l'animal.
On a essayé de le prévenir,
mais il ne l'a pas vu tout de suite.
Puis il l'a tué facilement,
trop facilement.
Il y avait là un mystère.
Sans prévenir, à son tour,
le sage est allé voir le gros animal
qui, lui, n'était toujours pas mort.
Ça nous a étonnés
car le sage est d'habitude très prudent.
Il a été le premier à comprendre.
L'animal n'était pas si dangereux.
On pouvait le garder au bout d'une lance.
Si on l'approchait
de trop près, il piquait.
Il y avait aussi une odeur qui restait
sur les mains quand on le touchait.
C'est le premier nom
qu'on lui a donné.
On avait vaincu notre peur
et il dansait devant nous.
On ne se doutait pas de toutes
les conséquences de cette découverte,
de tout ce qu'on allait
pouvoir faire avec du feu.
On a compris que le feu mangeait
tout ce qu'on lui donnait,
et que plus on le nourrissait,
plus il grandissait.
Quand on soufflait dessus
et quand le vent le touchait,
il se mettait en colère,
mais on n'avait plus peur.
C'est bien plus tard,
par hasard, qu'on a découvert la cuisson.
On lui a donné une bête à manger
et l'odeur qui s'est répandue nous a plu.
Ça a été difficile
de lui reprendre un morceau,
On a continué à lui donner des animaux
pour le goût et aussi pour le ventre.
La viande cuite faisait moins mal
quand elle passait dans le ventre.
Cette histoire s'est produite
partout où il y avait des hommes.
Pas toujours de la même manière,
mais étrangement au même moment
sur toute la planète,
il y a 500 000 ans.
Le feu est arrivé dans notre vie
et l'a considérablement améliorée.
Il a durci les pointes de nos armes.
Il nous a défendus contre les fauves.
Il nous a éclairés, réchauffés,
rassurés pendant les longues nuits noires.
Sa conquête a été difficile
et parsemée d'échecs.
Il a fallu des milliers
de tentatives pour que naisse l'idée
que le feu puisse être allumé,
conservé puis éteint par l'homme.
Le froid est arrivé.
Des glaciations à répétition.
Les hommes qui se sont aventurés
au nord de l'Afrique se retrouvent
face à des glaciers.
Quand ils essaient
de redescendre vers le sud,
le niveau des océans a remonté.
Ils sont piégés.
Ils vont devoir affronter
les terribles conditions climatiques
de l'hiver boréal.
En Europe,
celui qui va résister
s'appelle Néandertal.
Néandertal est le descendant d'Erectus.
Son voyage l'a conduit
dans toute l'Europe.
Malgré le froid,
malgré la neige, il s'est adapté.
En surmontant les difficultés,
ce nouvel homme
est même devenu une force de la nature.
De toutes les espèces humaines,
Néandertal est le plus robuste,
le plus endurant.
Il va dominer l'Europe pendant
des centaines de milliers d'années.
Pendant les huit mois d'hiver,
seule la chasse permet
de se nourrir et de se vêtir.
Néandertal concentre toute son énergie
sur la traque des grands animaux.
Pisteur, fabricant d'armes
et de pièges, tanneur de peaux.
Toute son activité est tendue
vers un seul objectif : ses proies.
Il devient la créature
la plus dangereuse du monde animal.
Il connaît les pyrites
qui font des étincelles
et l'amadou qui s'enflamme
en un rien de temps.
Il maîtrise parfaitement le feu
et plus aucun prédateur ne l'intimide.
Il peut même débusquer les plus féroces
d'entre eux jusque dans leur tanière.
Ils sont quatre ce jour-là.
Quatre hommes déterminés
à passer à l'attaque.
Le chef a décidé
de laisser son fils dehors.
Le jeune doit monter la garde.
Pour tuer, ils seront assez de trois.
La bête doit dormir au fond de la grotte.
Il vaut mieux la découvrir
avant qu'elle ne se réveille.
Il y a eu des cris,
puis plus rien.
L'assaut a mal tourné.
L'ours s'est jeté sur eux.
Le chef est touché.
C'est ainsi que le jeune découvrit
que son père était parti
dans l'autre monde.
Quelque chose lui disait que
l'ours n'était pas le seul responsable.
Le fier.
Le fier jalousait le pouvoir de son père.
Le troisième chasseur
avait trouvé une autre issue.
Et soudain,
nous découvrîmes la Grande rivière,
celle dans laquelle l'astre
de lumière plongeait tous les soirs.
Les anciens en parlaient souvent,
mais personne
dans notre clan ne l'avait jamais vu.
Cette caverne sera parfaite
pour passer les mois de chaleur.
Le fier en a décidé ainsi.
Tout le clan est venu s'installer
dans la caverne de l'ours.
Nous avions assez
de viande pour les mois à venir,
il suffisait de la sécher.
Il fallait du bois, des outils.
Tout le monde s'est mis à l'ouvrage.
La femme du chef essayait
de le ramener dans notre monde.
C'est alors que nous avons compris
que le nouveau chef serait le fier.
Il a pris toutes les peaux du mort,
une à une, devant les yeux du jeune,
et le jeune n'a rien dit
quand le fier les a mises sur lui.
La femme et la fille
du chef n'ont rien dit non plus.
Personne n'a rien dit
et ça voulait dire que tout le monde
acceptait que le fier commande.
Les peaux du chef,
c'est un grand pouvoir,
surtout celle qui couvre la tête.
Elles gardent le courage
et la force de celui qui les a portés.
Le jeune comprenait maintenant
pourquoi son père
n'était pas ressorti vivant de la caverne.
Le fier l'avait aidé à partir.
Le fier aime le pouvoir
et il le voulait pour lui tout seul.
La femme du chef
n'avait plus de protecteur.
Elle voulait le rejoindre
dans l'autre monde,
mais tout le monde
sait que c'est impossible.
Quand un homme part
dans l'autre monde,
il faut l'accompagner
pour l'aider à trouver son chemin.
Pour l'aider dans la Grande traversée,
pour lui faciliter son chemin,
des signes le guideront
jusque dans l'autre monde.
En rentrant, le fier a dit
au jeune qu'il devait lui obéir,
sinon il irait lui aussi
dans l'autre monde
pour rejoindre son père.
Ensuite,
le fier s'est accouplé
avec la femme du chef.
Il avait pris sa vie,
son pouvoir, ses peaux
et maintenant sa compagne.
Le fils n'a rien fait.
Tout le monde savait
qu'il ne pouvait rien faire.
Le fier était maintenant le plus fort
et on avait tous besoin de lui.
Alors le fils est parti.
Un jour,
le fier sera plus vieux
et moins fort que lui
et il l'enverra dans l'autre monde.
Où est cet autre monde ?
Certains disent
qu'il est au-delà de la Grande rivière.
Comment le souffle et la chaleur
du cœur peuvent-ils voyager aussi loin ?
Nous sommes à -50 000 ans.
Des peuples d'humains, chasseurs,
cueilleurs, nomades et doués de conscience
sont installés dans tout l'ancien monde.
Mais tous ces hommes
ne sont pas nos ancêtres.
Notre ancêtre existe pourtant
et il est parmi eux.
Il s'appelle Homo sapiens,
l'homme sage,
celui qui sait
et il est né dans un endroit inconnu.
Néandertal domine
toujours l'Europe et l'Orient.
Il vit en petites tribus familiales,
se déplace selon les saisons
en suivant les migrations de son gibier.
Il profite des richesses de la nature.
Mais ses jours sont comptés.
Il va disparaître
dans quelques générations.
Avant de partir, il sera au cœur
de la plus tragique des histoires.
C'est arrivé un jour d'été.
La mer s'était retirée
et nous en avions profité
pour ramasser les petites viandes salées.
Notre clan était installé
dans la caverne de l'ours.
Nous n'étions plus que
dix hommes et deux femmes.
Aucun enfant n'était né depuis longtemps.
C'est en rentrant
que nous avons aperçu le premier signe.
Au début,
Œil de glace a cru à des ennemis.
Il a envoyé tout le monde
se réfugier dans la caverne.
Il est resté avec son frère.
Œil de glace et son frère
n'avaient jamais vu ça.
Ils étaient physiquement différents.
Leurs vêtements étaient différents.
Leurs peaux étaient
de différentes couleurs.
Ils avaient des armes étranges
et ils savaient aussi prendre le poisson,
et même mieux que nous.
Il y avait des femmes,
beaucoup de femmes,
certaines avec des cheveux
de la couleur du soleil.
On n'avait jamais entendu
parler de ces êtres étranges.
Mais d'où venaient-ils ?
Que faisaient-ils ici ?
Ils viennent de l'autre monde.
Ils nous cherchent.
Il ne faut pas qu'ils nous trouvent.
On n'avait jamais vu
Œil de glace dans un tel état.
Pendant un moment, ce fut la panique.
Puis il prit la parole
et nous raconta ce qu'il avait vu.
Ils sont très nombreux,
tous avec un visage plat,
des petits nez pointus
et des jambes très longues.
Ils ont, elles aussi,
des lances très fines et pointues,
et au bout des doigts, des petites griffes
avec lesquelles ils piquent leur fourrure.
Ils mettent
des coquillages sur leur peau,
de la terre sur tout le corps
et des os dans leurs cheveux.
Ils ont des petites cavernes en peau.
Il faut faire attention, très attention.
Ils viennent d'un autre monde.
Ce soir-là, nous sommes
tous restés au fond de la caverne,
serrés les uns contre les autres,
sans feu pour nous chauffer,
sans feu pour cuisiner le poisson.
On a d'abord pensé
qu'ils viendraient nous chercher
pour nous manger.
On les a attendus
sans dire une seule parole.
Mais ils ne sont pas venus.
On ne pouvait pas
rester là à ne rien faire.
Au bout de la nuit,
Œil de glace a pris une décision.
Après tout, ils nous ressemblaient.
Il fallait savoir.
Il fallait essayer.
Il n'y avait que des femmes
et des enfants et un homme blessé.
Où étaient les autres ?
On s'est tous lancés
avec la peur au ventre.
Il y avait plus de nourriture
que nous n'en avions jamais vu,
et des flûtes en os comme les nôtres,
mais plus petites et plus fines.
Une des femmes s'est avancée.
Elle voulait nous donner à manger.
Œil de glace s'est méfié.
Puis il s'est intéressé à la femme,
de la voir si proche,
de pouvoir toucher ses cheveux.
Il a voulu la prendre et rien d'autre.
Les autres femmes
ont voulu nous offrir de la viande,
mais Œil de glace n'en voulait pas.
Une seule chose
l'intéressait maintenant,
prendre la femme.
Quand elles se sont mises en colère,
on a compris
qu'on ne pouvait pas partir comme ça,
qu'il fallait laisser
quelque chose en échange.
Alors on leur a laissé
deux lièvres et un gibier à plumes,
même si ça n'a pas eu
l'air de leur plaire.
Quand Néandertal découvre Sapiens,
il est fasciné par son apparence,
ses parures,
ses habits, ses bijoux.
La sophistication de ses outils
et de ses armes
n'en finisse pas de l'étonner.
Quand Sapiens
se retrouve face à Néandertal,
elle le prend pour une brute
sous-développée et ignorante,
un sauvage, un anthropophage.
Mais bientôt,
elle découvre derrière ce faciès ingrat
un homme habité par des croyances
et pratiquant des coutumes complexes.
Il enterre ses morts
comme elle enterre les siens.
Un homme intelligent et sensible
avec lequel on peut communiquer.
Entre eux deux,
un échange est possible,
mais il est limité
par un facteur purement biologique.
Aucun enfant
ne peut naître de leur union.
Néandertal et Sapiens
ne peuvent se reproduire.
Ils sont génétiquement trop différents.
Œil de glace ne le sait pas,
et il croit à ce moment
pouvoir repeupler son clan.
Il veut la rassurer,
il veut l'adopter et la séduire.
Il prend son temps
car son espoir est immense.
Il voudrait des enfants de cette femme.
La femme sapiens
est intriguée par ces hommes,
mais elle ne veut pas rester parmi eux
et elle sait comment prévenir les siens.
Néandertal et Sapiens
vont se côtoyer pendant des millénaires.
Ils vont s'apporter mutuellement
de nombreuses
richesses techniques et culturelles.
Mais rien n'empêchera
le mystérieux déclin de Néandertal,
et l'extraordinaire réussite de Sapiens.
Comment Sapiens est-il arrivé ?
Où est-il né ?
En Afrique ?
En Asie ?
Partout au même moment ?
Le mystère reste entier.
Entre -100 000 et -40 000 ans,
Sapiens bouge,
migre partout sur la planète,
jusqu'en Australie et en Amérique.
Et partout, les populations humaines
qu'il rencontre vont disparaître.
L'hiver arrive à grands pas.
Dans la caverne de l'ours,
il ne reste que trois survivants :
Œil de glace,
son fils et la dernière femme.
Elle est enceinte et ne peut entreprendre
la grande migration hivernale.
Œil de glace va partir seul
et il sait
qu'il ne reverra pas ses proches.
Ce monde n'est plus fait pour eux.
Œil de glace s'en va.
Il ne verra pas le dernier
des Néanderthal tomber.
La disparition de Néanderthal
demeure un phénomène mal connu.
Ont-ils été décimés par
des maladies apportées par Sapiens ?
Ont-ils été victimes
d'une soudaine baisse de la natalité ?
Les causes sont sans doute multiples.
Le peuple Néandertal a lentement décliné
parce qu'il était moins bien adapté,
plus vulnérable
et parce qu'il avait moins d'enfants.
Œil de glace a voulu revoir
une dernière fois ce lieu
où la femme sapiens avait vécu.
Elle était partie si vite.
Néandertal a disparu en laissant
derrière lui des trésors de coutumes,
de croyances,
de progrès technologiques,
mais aussi une nouvelle conscience
de la place de l'homme dans le monde,
un goût pour l'au-delà
et un culte des songes
et des visions de l'imaginaire.
Le dernier Néandertal
mourut il y a 25 000 ans
et sa fin fut biologiquement naturelle.
Son sang n'a jamais pu
se mêler aux nôtres.
Nous ne sommes pas leurs fils de sang.
Nous sommes leurs héritiers,
ils nous ont transmis leur culture.
Cette culture,
ces croyances héritées du fond des âges,
Homo sapiens va les fixer
avec les siennes
sur les parois de ses cavernes.
Après avoir exploré la terre,
il invente l'art et se lance
à la conquête d'un nouveau monde,
un monde qui le projette à grande vitesse
vers le futur, le monde de l'imaginaire.
Homo sapiens, c'est nous.
Nous sommes désormais
les seuls représentants
de la grande famille
des hominidés autrefois si variée,
aujourd'hui,
la dernière espèce d'homme sur la planète.
Nos ancêtres nous laissent
un fabuleux héritage,
des millions d'années d'évolution
conquises avec la rage de vivre
et l'espoir d'un meilleur lendemain.
Des millions de tentatives,
d'échecs et de chemins d'errance
pour nous permettre
de mieux comprendre notre planète,
d'aller au-delà de nos limites.
Tout cela est le don que nos parents,
aussi lointains soient-ils, nous ont fait.
Une seule famille
a engendré notre espèce.
Une seule lignée
a donné naissance à tous les peuples
qui vivent aujourd'hui sur notre planète.
Beaucoup de mystères
restent encore à élucider.
Mais tous les jours,
les silhouettes
des hommes et des femmes
qui ont fait notre préhistoire
sortent peu à peu de l'oubli.
Ils s'appellent Toumaï, Orrorin,
Anamensis, Lucy, Habilis, Ergaster,
Erectus, Néandertal, Cro-Magnon.
Tous les jours,
nous en apprenons un peu plus sur eux,
sur nous, sur l'histoire
qui nous rassemble tous,
quelles que soient nos origines.
Nous sommes
aujourd'hui des sapiens sapiens,
mais demain, qui serons-nous ?